to really understand the priorities of
US presidents look at their budgets
Donald Trump has just released his four
point eight nine trillion dollar
spending vision to members of Congress
the headlines more big hikes for
military spending and cuts to some
programs benefiting the elderly and
children trump's budget also proposes a
21 percent cut in foreign aid tremendous
waste and tremendous fraud there's a
vision to eliminate America's ballooning
federal spending deficit by the year
2035 the plan is to reform social safety
net programs food stamp programs that
feed the poor and benefits for disabled
broken the economy is intended to offset
the cuts we're in the midst of a great
American comeback we're creating the
most prosperous economy and the most
inclusive society ever to exist actually
but Democrats in Congress say Trump's
budget hurts the poor and favors the
wealthy they say there's no chance this
presidential wishlist in his current
form will pass into law so why bother
with these and other proposals like
spending to repair America's crumbling
infrastructure or bring internet to
rural parts of the United States this
budget is all about politics rural
voters are critical for Trump's
reelection
so is keeping this promise Mexico is in
fact you'll soon find out
paying for the wall okay Trump made the
promise in 2016 and again last month
that he'll build a wall along the
southern border of the United States and
Mexico to cut illegal immigration
Trump's pledge helped him win the White
House and even though Mexico's never
paid for construction and the wall is
far from complete Trump's making the
pitch again president Trump's budget is
little more than a blueprint for
Americans of his spending priorities as
he makes the case on the campaign trail
for voters to re-elect him for a second
term
Kimberly hellcat al Jazeera the White